moi j'adore cette émission rien a vu sa
lame c'est sûr vous allez la faire un
jour sur qui va vous j'aimerais trop
franchement susurre et frédéric lopez si
l'on regarde pense que big three au lit
certaines plaies ouais c'est vrai nom
l'arrivée on la regardait toujours en
famille et toi et moi je suis pas
d'accord avec gilles je le trouve super
poétique et on apprend ya toujours des
messages de faim il explique que c'est
en danger cet endroit du globe et toute
l'afrique at elle changé à tour et cette
émission bernard à la mois-ci m'appelle
j'irai pas non mais vous appelle
c'est pas la patate épaules des gazaouis
les parents des montants que nous allons
cependant rendez vous chez point soleil
simplement merci c'est pas ben ben allez
pas à dormir par terre et tout ça non
mais entrer des gens je veux bien mais
d'avoir des caméras pour rencontrer des
gens dans nos arénas dormir par terre
c'est moi que je franchement je trouve
qu'il est une magnifique émission
oui ça je le verrais bien de faire aussi
bytes à doumbia moi j'suis sûr vous êtes
là vous allez les faire vous allez la
faire les deux futurs frédéric lopez
ça va lui donner des idées il va le
faire avec avec vous avant tokyo georges
veut crever de faim c'est quoi ton
comminatoire
je sentais que j'étais pas emballé par
ce moi j'aime bien les clubs je kiffe
àmilan